Next question today.
Hey David, I noticed that you don't use some
of the Soviet terminology that is becoming
in Vogue with part of the left, like calling
people comrades and talking about things being
read in a positive way.
Why don't you use that terminology?
Listen, I've sort of talked about this before.
Um, I'm not a communist.
I'm not a socialist.
I don't think that Leninism or Stalinist Marxism
are the directions that we should be going.
Uh, as a society.
My model is one of social democracy, taking
many of the elements that have worked well
in Scandinavian Northern European countries,
uh, and tweaking them and doing things that
account for the reality that the United States
is more diverse than a lot of those countries.
And the United States has a lot of different
other cultural elements going on.
So that, that's basically my model.
I don't look back at the Soviet union, um,
with, uh, Rose colored glasses or in this
nostalgic way, you know, in the same way that
the right talks about the golden age of the
1950s or whatever.
And I just think that doesn't make any sense.
I also don't look back at the Soviet era and
say that's what we should be striving for.
So I don't know who you're referring to.
I, the only thing I can think of is I know
that a Hassan piker from the young Turks from
TYT network has or had a show called Ajit
prop and okay.
I mean, you know, call the show what you want.
I don't know that that's necessarily what
I would call a show.
I don't need to make reference, um, to Soviet
terminology.
I don't know of anybody who calls others comrades,
but I believe you that it exists.
It's just not interesting to me.
You know, I don't there, I don't think my
movement and the policy and ideas that I support
of, uh, economic justice and, um, uh, welfare
programs that work and lifting people up and
reducing inequality and fixing a lot of the
things that aren't working, I don't think
I need Soviet terminology to make that a reality.
I don't think that it helps.
And also the other thing is in general, I'm
not that big a fan aside from Soviet terminology.
When I'm trying w I am a progressive, I want
to move forward.
So in general, I don't see the world as here's
the phase we want to go back to.
We to be moving forward.
We might incorporate, incorporate economic
or cultural or societal elements from some
time in the past, which might have overlap
with some other movement or country or era
or phase.
And that's fine.
But for me as a progressive, I'm seeing us
going to something new and unprecedented.
So it's against my nature to say let's call
each other comrades or let's do our Ajit prop
or use Soviet terminology.
Uh, because I'm not looking to go back to
something.
I might incorporate things that worked from
the past, but I'm looking to go forward and
do something new.
So I'm not particularly interested in adopting
old terminology when what I want to do is
actually see progress as the word progressive
contains within it a at M illogically if that
is a, if that is a word.
So that's my view.